this is Lebanon's day of anger thousands
of protestors determined to force their
way to the country's parliament building
their route blocked by riot police
standing behind barbed wire barricades
hurling rocks sticks and pretty much
anything else they could get their hands
on demonstrators try to push the police
back and this was the response water
cannon
and volley after volley of teargas
ambulances rushed hundreds of injured to
nearby hospitals while security forces
dragged demonstrators away others had to
take shelter in a nearby mosque one of
this country's most iconic buildings
turned into a makeshift clinic
for over three months downtown Beirut
has been the epicenter of a nationwide
movement calling for the removal of the
entire political establishment the
country's leadership has promised reform
but so far delivered nothing
transforming 94 days of what has been
overwhelmingly peaceful protests into
this a crippling economic crisis has
seen jobs lost to people's salaries cuts
and medical supplies running short
Lebanon's financial institutions have
borne the brunt of people's anger banks
have kept cash withdrawals to just a few
hundred pounds a month leaving many
unable to pay rent school fees and
hospital bills
[Applause]
Lebanon is in crisis it's politicians
seemingly incapable of addressing their
people's concerns they'll need to do so
quickly or risk watching this country
collapse into an even more dangerous
cycle of violence
Sanja for Sky News Beirut
[Music]